let's start first with uh you pretty
much had the opportunity to do whatever
you wanted uh in business uh in tech etc
why you wanna run for politics and like
how important is any individual uh
political seat in terms of actually
creating some sort of change uh in the
united states
i mean i guess i intend to find out you
know i think a
u.s senate seat is enormously more
powerful than most u.s senators give it
credit for right just look at the
cultural power of ascendancy right now
you've got uh you know biological men
sort of you know transitioning or
whatever competing on women swim teams
and no none of our leaders are talking
about this
that's pretty crazy you've got open
borders you've got massive inflation
because the government printed what like
six trillion dollars in the last year
and we've got a few good republicans i
think but like man not enough people are
talking about this and really uh
educating voters and helping people
understand that like the democrat
leadership in charge has failed um so
obviously a huge part of the job is
passing the right bills blocking the bad
ones but i think just the cultural power
of the seat is um kind of under
underexplored and i'm uh it's true i
have a really good gig with with peter
thiel you know running his uh family
office but this just this seems like the
most important thing i could be doing
arizona's a swing state i think this
senate race that i'm in is going to
determine the balance of power in the
whole us senate um and it's it's just
important i feel called to do it and i
know i can win and do a good job
so let's start uh maybe with the
economic uh kind of situation obviously
uh it seems like our debt ceiling just
goes up and up and up regardless of who
the the president is uh but with that
we're living right now with eight
percent uh inflation in the official
numbers unofficially probably somewhere
in the the teens what's your general
read in terms of uh kind of the mistakes
that have been made to get us here and
then like what is the solution right i
think part of what uh a big portion of
the american people uh they feel like
politics is just arguing all the time
and i think one of the things that um
has been part of your approach which i
think is pretty effective is like hey
there's like real solutions that could
be pursued whether we do it or not is up
for debate but like how do you think
about getting out of the economic
situation that we're in
right well one it is kind of hard to put
the cat back in the bag here right uh
the the simplest thing we can do on the
inflation front is to stop printing so
much money um it's it's totally
unsustainable you know our national
debts passed 30 trillion dollars now and
i get the sense that republicans who
used to be sort of you know
hawks on this
kind of they're not watching anymore
it's it's it's kind of just like well
you know and now you have modern
monetary theory right the
pseudo-academic jargon that just says oh
it's you know it doesn't matter we owe
it to ourselves you can sort of get away
with this for as long as you want and i
really fear that's not true um you
mentioned official inflation at eight
percent and yeah sure if you define the
basket of goods to exclude you know food
energy right gas prices i think the real
costco basket uh probably costs 20 to 30
percent more than it did last year um
and so for a lot of people um you know
who opine about inflation and the
opinion making classes inflation's just
an annoyance right or uh economic
abstraction but for so many voters that
i meet on the campaign trail in arizona
this is like life and death stuff you
know this is this is not this is
existential um so you got to stop
printing so much money and and we got to
get people back to work
when you start to think about things
like wages uh real estate prices it
feels like uh inflation obviously people
think in the consumer goods space but
wages haven't kept up uh also things
like the cost of a home the average home
in america i think just cost over five
hundred thousand dollars which is you
know pretty insane number when you think
about what that means um is the ideas
really around uh hey the government
should stop printing and then like how
do you think about things like financial
education right and it feels almost i
always say that like the gap between
those that are benefiting in this
situation and those aren't
people would like to draw the line
around wealth but really it's an
education gap like some people know how
to benefit from this environment by
holding investable assets et cetera and
then 45 of americans don't so how do you
think about like the overlay of the
education uh uh for personal finance etc
with a lot of this
i was just uh touring a charter school
in arizona and i was blown away because
they have a year-long program the first
semester is personal finance and the
second semester is entrepreneurship
and um two things are remarkable one
that's just a really cool program right
and i got to talk to some of these kids
in the entrepreneurship class and uh you
know you could you could just see how
happy they were to be there right and
they were starting all these micro
businesses and you start with nothing
and you try to see if you can end the
semester with like 500 bucks or whatever
um so what a valuable thing that is but
then the most remarkable thing about it
is how rare a program like that is right
and i think in the first so you got like
11th graders they're listening to dave
ramsey you know um
they've never heard any of this stuff
before they don't know what a checkbook
is let alone how to balance it
for them you know and increasingly we're
in a cashless society so maybe some of
them know about crypto but mainly it's
just you know put it on the parents
credit card and
they don't they're not acquainted with
this stuff
they're not learning it in school and so
i think that that one gem of a program
could be some kind of model like bring
back home ac right bring back financial
literacy class bring back shop class
while we're at it but school should be
useful
instead of just graduating a bunch of
people that don't have any skills hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time